nicolas vidal bonjour merci d'être en
direct sur rt france
alors tout d'abord quelle est votre
lecture personnelle de cette nouvelle
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
j'ai eu un tir de libération
effectivement et j'écoutais dominique
pradalié je suis extrêmement d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit j'écoutais cigare
soir au collègue alexis poulain je suis
encore une fois d'accord avec ça pour
moi ce nouveau schéma aujourd'hui c'est
une dispersion de la démocratie est une
sommation ne pas informer un cadre légal
je rappellerai quand même le cadre légal
aujourd'hui pour un journaliste si la
démocratie est aussi utile d'informer
les français donc on se retrouve
abandonné dans une dérive de plus en
plus autoritaire à nous empêcher de
faire entre de travail alors non
monsieur le ministre monsieur darmon
n'encadre pas le travail des
journalistes c'est encore en contre
pouvoir qui ne plus en plus maigres
aujourd'hui en france et après se pose
aussi la question des médias
indépendants des citoyens des médias
mais ce riche qu'on appelle ces médias
meanstream il va falloir voir comment ça
va être fait mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui ce nouveau schéma du
maintien de l'ordre
pose de ce très sérieuses questions sur
la liberté d'informer sur les vertus de
la halle et venir ma liberté d'informer
parce que new media nous on est chez
nous tous les médias indépendants et
très sincèrement je bous l'auditorat
qu'on va sur une manifestation on est
quand même assez anxieux alors bien
entendu sur manifestations il ya
toujours des risques
c'est évident mais là aujourd'hui au
nickel de 13 ans tuée même depuis le
début de 26 ans riche des jeunes donc là
on est en train de réduire de plus en
plus d'autres prix car et démocratique a
informé les français alors donné une
version de la démocratie et de ce qui se
passe réellement
il ça c'est vraiment vraiment grand coup
de canif dans ce qu'yves voilà notre
démocratie et notre liberté d'informer
nous médias indépendants mais portant
aussi qui avons numéro de carte de pêche
qui sera ensuite nous avons nous le
retard de près d'en conclure en mesure
aujourd'hui de pouvoir informer les gens
de ce qui se passe alors le texte aborde
la question de l'équipement et de la
sécurité des journalistes présents lors
des manifestations ils pourront
d'ailleurs gardé ses équipements dès
lors que leur identification est
confirmée et leur comportement exemple
de toute infraction provocation que vous
inspire le terme provocation
fonction deux délits finalement c'est à
dire qu'on pourrait penser que le
journaliste lui-même sourire
potentiellement ils pourraient commettre
des délits et le juge des poux je crois
que très sincèrement une nouvelle fois
assez des mots c'est une espèce de
génoise absolument technocratique et je
le ferai d'ailleurs que si ça avait été
le cas à charleroi
cette mesure ce plan avait été votée ou
même posé en hongrie en pologne en rue
emmanuel macron nous aurait fait un
tweet ou le jean yves le drian honte une
série de grands médias qui serait à
l'aube et contre la liberté de la presse
pour le dos de dan charisme l'autocratie
aujourd'hui je j'écoutais alexis poulain
il ressort sur votre antenne très
sincèrement il a raison alexis
aujourd'hui dans la presse j'ai fait ma
robe veste matin et je suis texte
scandalisé plusieurs grands médias
meanstream aujourd'hui ne sait même pas
effectivement de 7,2 ce point là qui
extrêmement gravissime c'est gravissime
et ça suffit ça suffit scandent alizés
fait sincèrement que des grands médias
comme ça n'est pas douter ce point là et
d'idées que pour la plupart finalement
reprendre en copiant copier et coller
des notes de ce texte la face est
absolument c'est absolument édifiant
exploit alors le snj rappelle également
comment plus d'une centaine de
journalistes ont été empêchés de
travailler
ces derniers mois selon vous cette
doctrine va aggraver la situation
bien entendu quand vous mettez sur le
même vu un journaliste un manifestant
est à dire que mon année on veut se
disperser on ne gagne et une sommation
ou une vivant toussaint vous des
enchères tu es aussi qui est une
sommation
on va être obligé de se disperser sinon
on pourrait être en garde-à-vue
d'inquiéter fouillé au nous journalistes
on est là pour faire de la formation on
est là pour être le contact vous montrer
ce qui se passe réellement
on peut par moment donné nous imposer
nous encadrer 94 pas notre travail
monsieur darmanin quand on est sur une
manifestation du genre prend des risques
parce que c'est risquer une
manifestation que de savoir mais là
aujourd'hui on peut pas se disperser
comme ça dans le tout venant de la foule
on est là pour informer si on disperse
qui aurait ce type de l'information que
reste-t-il de la liberté d'informer
d'iris et c'est eux très sincèrement
cette mesure je le dis elle est
absolument liberticide contre ce petit
contre-pouvoir qui reste l'est de moins
en moins nombreux à faire de la
formation l'information objective et
je remercie artisans de faire ce sujet
là dessus et c'est compliqué on peut pas
être considéré comme devant des
centaines de manifestants c'est
absolument une nouvelle fois édifiant
merci beaucoup et nicolas vidal d'avoir
réagi sur rtl france je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de la publication de
putsch médias